all right guys today i'm going to my
siblings and asking them the important
questions
hey adam what
do you love me no
okay
i'm gonna
i'm gonna keep going all right
chaz yeah chaz
um do you love me
sure
okay we got one yes one yes
i'm gonna continue to the rest of the
house
all right ellie ellie do you love me
say yeah all right come on
all right
all right we're gonna
i'm moving to england that's why
my room's a mess right now
hey eva do you love me
i'll answer i have to go get mom from
the airport okay can i just get a yes or
no
what if you go get her
okay i'm gonna keep moving
hey amelia do you love me don't answer
that until she gets mom from the airport
oh my gosh
sometimes sometimes like how much of the
time 50
is it that higher is it lower
it depends
on what
if you're home or not
so if i'm home do you love me no
so if i'm not home you love me
more
damn what if i react to a youtube video
with you oh no i've been asking you for
months okay yeah i'll do it if you go
get mom uh no
all right so it's okay we don't need
evo's validation i'll keep going i need
somebody to get mom okay well
i mean i can't mom's mom's mad at me
right now i can't go get her
well she'll be mad at me if nobody goes
to get her okay well
i have a horse to take care of why don't
you go take care of the horse after
because the barn will be closed
why do you go now they'll see you here i
can go to the barn and i'll get there at
five
and then i'll be there for three hours
oh do you remember the last time i
needed you to um do some how much are
you paying me remember last time i
needed you to drive some me something
what did i do give you an id so you
could go get drunk with a friend okay
i wasn't getting drunk i did not get
drunk let's start there i went to
karaoke which is a hobby of mine well
maybe you should have brought your id i
also got ellie's papers in order and
offered to drive her to the vet for no
cost at all no i said i'd pay you i know
but i didn't ask you to okay well so
what am i getting paid in this
interaction
the cost of how much you would make on
the youtube video that i react to you
with
i don't make enough on youtube
what do you think amelia should i go get
it and mom just go do it eva's busy
stinky well it's this way you can mend
your relationship yeah
ooh i'd rather not she's mad right now
yeah i can't really help you with this
one
i don't know why would you agree to it
if you couldn't go
because
mom told me it would be later in there
she told me she needed to be able to
pick up at like 8 30.
i was like oh i can do that the barn
will be closed she sent you the flight
information it was later
yeah uh
what about chaz he wouldn't do it
or adam can't adam can't either why
they're not doing his homework and
trousers i think he's going to the gym
so
go bother one of them
hannah you're the only one who's just
doing it for no the only reason you're
not doing it because you have a fight
with mom okay even if you were to fight
with mom you wouldn't do that boom
says the truth you're welcome actually
what did i have
last time i picked mama
okay amelia is that cap or no cap that's
cow
[Music]